- Knights of the Round Table
were expected to adhere
to a strict moral standard
of piety, honor, bravery,
and courtesy called chivalry.
But considering that they
often spent their days
killing and rampaging at
the behest of their Lord,
that must have required
some next level compartmentalization.
This duality is reflected
in the various versions of a key figure
who appears in Arthurian
legends throughout history,
Sir Gawain.
In some stories, Gawain is the embodiment
of chivalry excellence.
He rescues maidens, masterminds quests,
and takes out pirates.
In others, Gawain is
very much the anti-hero,
Even inciting the fall of King Arthur.
This vacillation of Gawain's character
is most clearly on display
in what is perhaps the most
well-known Arthurian legend,
the 14th century chivalric poem,
"Sir Gawain and the Green Knight."
The story is a generally favorable account
of Gawain's character,
but it also lays bare the
ambiguities of his position.
Is Gawain's conflicted
depiction in "The Green Night"
a criticism of chivalry and heroism
as it was known at the time.
Perhaps it is a commentary on
the human condition at large.
(dramatic music)
Written anonymously and
rediscovered centuries later,
"Sir Gawain and the Green Night"
is set at Christmastime
and involves an intruder,
and that's where the
similarities to "Home Alone" end.
While Arthur and his knights are feasting,
they're interrupted by
a giant green knight
in green garments riding a
green horse right into the hall.
The green knight claims
he seeks no violence,
only a game.
He invites someone to
strike him with his own ax,
and in return,
the volunteer must consent
to the green knight striking him
in one year and one day's time.
So who's it gonna be?
Arthur is about to rise to the challenge
to save face until the
loyal Gawain steps in.
For some reason, Gawain
decides to go big or go home.
He rolls a natural 20
and chops the Green
Knight's head clean off.
Game over, right?
Well, imagine his surprise
when the green knight
calmly scoops up his laughing head
and orders going to find him
at the Green Chapel next year
where he will repay the blow.
It may not sound like
something that would catch on,
but this game actually has a name.
Popularized in Celtic
and medieval mythology,
the beheading game, yes, really,
usually involves a young warrior
being invited to behead
and submit to a beheading,
kind of like an ultra
stakes power slap league.
In a famous Irish myth,
evil lord Bricriu invites
three of Ireland's best heroes to dinner
and pits them against each other.
For their final challenge,
a mysterious warrior orders
them to chop off his head
and come back the next night
for him to return the blow.
- So you want us to chop your head off?
- Yes, please.
- But why?
- I guess you could say,
I want to stay ahead of the game.
(rock music)
- [Emily] Only one of
the heroes, Cu Chulainn,
shout out to our Cu Chulainn episode,
shows up cementing his
status as the winner.
- Guess that makes me head of the class.
(rock music)
- [Emily] In another legend,
Arthur's night Caradoc
is obliged to behead a hooded stranger
and submit to a beheading.
The beheading game is like
the ultimate test of honor.
Will you keep your word to play the game
even if it means your death?
Meanwhile, the people on my trivia team
have always some kind of
excuse for not showing up,
even though I made it very clear
that pub trivia is a commitment.
After a very anxious year,
Gawain must either stick
to the terms of the game
or lose his honor.
So he rides out to meet his fate.
After encountering a variety of enemies
and marvels that are not
described, but trust us,
they were amazing,
he arrives at the grand castle
of Lord and Lady Bertilak.
The Bertilaks tell him that
he's close to the Green Chapel,
but offer to let him rest
up with them for a few days.
Gawain's in no rush to
get his head chopped off,
so he happily accepts
not knowing that he's just walked into
yet another bizarre game.
Lord Bertilak declares that
he will go hunting every day
and share his spoils with Gawain.
But in return,
Gawain must give the Lord whatever
he's received during
his day at the castle.
On the first day,
Lady Bertilak sneaks
into Gawain's chambers
and attempts to seduce him.
He rebuffs her politely
with a chaste kiss.
When the Lord returns from the hunt,
he shares a deer with Gawain
and Gawain gives him a single kiss.
On the second day, Gawain
permits two kisses from the lady,
which he passes on to the
lord in exchange for a boar.
On the third day,
the lady lavish is
Gawain with three kisses
and something extra.
I know you think we're
gonna know this is going,
but I promise you it's not.
A magical green and gold girdle,
which she promises will protect him
from the green night.
When the Lord returns,
Gawain has a dilemma.
Keeping the girdle secret
would break his promise,
but might save his life
and avoid a very awkward conversation.
Like many mythical heroes,
Gawain is constantly
trying to prove his worth,
but gets confused by games
with arbitrary rules and
unclear expectations.
In medieval times,
there was a fine line
between games and violence.
Okay, still kind of true.
Dueling and hunting were recreational,
but they were also part of
a knight's violent duties.
By participating in
both the beheading game
and a hunting game,
Gawain is simultaneously
navigating the worlds
of violence and sport
and apparently sex.
And by accepting the spoils of the hunt
while keeping the girdle,
he sacrifices his honor.
Finally, Gawain arrives
at the Green Chapel,
an uncanny grassy cave and
confronts the green knight.
Despite his fear,
he kneels at the giant's
feet and offers his neck
as promised,
the green knight lifts
his ax above his head,
swings it down at Gawain's neck,
but only nicks him drawing
a few drops of blood.
Gawain is in shock,
but the green knight burst out laughing
and commends Gawain for
upholding the bargain.
He reveals himself to be
none other than Lord Bertilak
disguised by the magic of the
old sorceress Morgan le Fay
to test Arthur's knights.
It was all a prank, I guess.
This mirrors the ending
of other beheading games
and "Bricriu's Feast,"
Cu Chulainn is spared on
account of his bravery
while Paradox's story ends with his enemy
striking him with a blunt sword
and praising him for his courage.
On the one hand,
these stories make light
of the hero's struggle
by turning a serious bargain
into a courtly jest.
On the other,
they can be read as a critique of heroism
and its hollow violent nature.
The story of Gawain and the green knight
shares this dual meaning.
It pokes fun at lofty chivalric standards,
but it also interrogates the impossibility
of these standards.
While Gawain should be proud
of mostly passing the test,
he feels like a coward
for breaking his word
about the girdle
and arrives back at
court an emotional wreck.
But luckily,
he's got his round table
bros to lift him back up.
As far as they're concerned,
he survived a terrifying
ordeal with his reputation,
more or less intact.
They even all start wearing
green and gold girdles
to celebrate him.
- Gawain's our hero.
- Thanks.
Does my epic beard help?
- Absolutely, yes.
Green and gold girdle crew represent.
(both laugh)
- Lord and Lady Bertilak
have a really messed up relationship.
- Yeah.
- Gawain's hero status
is a Christmas miracle.
The Christmas setting is no accident.
It highlights another
tension that poor Gawain
has to navigate.
That between Christian and pagan worlds.
A Christian holiday is
literally interrupted
by an explicitly pagan figure,
with his green skin, wild
beard, and bare chest,
the green night clearly represents nature.
And resembles the mythical green man,
a face encased in leaves that appears
in ancient artwork from
India to the British Isles.
Green was also the color of
witchcraft and the devil,
and there's something
definitely supernatural
about a giant who can pick
up his own severed head.
Magic in the form of the girdle
is also what punctures Gawain's
otherwise watertight honor.
And yet, the test of Gawain's honor
is only possible because of sorcery,
which enables the
transformation of Lord Bertilak
into a green giant.
These chaotic circumstances
reveal the entanglement of
paganism and Christianity,
which shaped the medieval worldview.
No wonder Gawain is confused.
Gawain's inconsistency can be
attributed to his character
or lack thereof.
The lack of a significant trait
leaves him open to our projections,
but it's also what makes him
the most human of Arthur's knights.
In the end,
it's hard not to feel a
little sorry for Gawain.
By just trying to do the right thing,
he got tricked into
volunteering for beheading,
made a treacherous journey
towards his own certain death.
Got sucked into an eccentric
couple's weird sex games
all to get laughed at by the green knight.
Still, Gawain arguably
manages to stay honorable
along the way except for the girdle.
But come on, who wouldn't
wanna keep the girdle?
Later depictions of Gawain
have shared the sympathy.
"The Once and Future King" fantasy novels
concoct a traumatic childhood for Gawain.
While the recent film adaptation,
"The Green Knight" portrays
him as a very human hero,
trying to make the best
of baffling circumstances.
In the comic,
"Once and Future"
Arthurian legend is retold
in a modern day exploration
of the power of storytelling
with Gawain's mantle taken up by Rose,
one of the female protagonists.
While these expansions to Gawain lore
and modern day mythmaking
more explicitly comment
on changing attitudes
towards gender and heroism,
the internal conflicts at
the core of the narrative
continue to reflect the
complexity of humanity
and our brutal world.
We might not play the beheading
game at parties anymore,
but the tension between
entertainment and violence
is still very much a part of culture.
The legends of Gawain are a testament
that even a night of the Roundtable
can be susceptible to pitfalls,
mistakes, and human error.
Not to mention the
hypocrisies of chivalry,
which the original anonymous
author seemed to recognize.
Ultimately, Gawain is a
hero who is thoroughly
shaped by the world around him.
His challenge lies in
upholding cultural norms,
but his power lies in exposing the cracks
and contradictions that
underlie those norms.
So if you've been following along
for this season of "Fate and Fabled,"
we're doing our favorite Pantheon picks.
So for my pick for this episode,
I'm going with the Morrigan.
- Ooh.
Nice choice.
- Thank you.
- The Morrigan, I just think
is really interesting perspective wise,
'cause she's one and many,
she can also shapeshift into a crow.
And you know how much I love birds.
So the Morrigan's my pick.
- Yeah, that's great.
Great pick.
- [Emily] Stay tuned for our next episode
and you'll get to hear
our next Pantheon pick.
Before you go, we wanna
hear your feedback.
Every year, PBS Digital Studios
surveys our audience
helping us understand
what you enjoy on YouTube
and what you would want
to see us make more of.
You also get to vote on new show ideas.
So it'd be great if "Fate and Fabled" fans
were well represented in the polls.
There's a link in the description.
Thanks in advance.
- [Speaker] Whoa.
- Do I then fall over?
- [Speaker] I laughed.
Yeah, there you go.
- Green and gold girdle...